[Musique]
l'arrivée de donald trump à la maison
blanche il ya deux ans on peut dire et à
bouleverser l'univers politique que ce
soit aux états unis et partout dans le
monde et l'automne dernier le
journaliste bob bout de voile publier
son livre peur trump à la maison blanche
il y dressait le portrait d'un président
complètement désordonnée impulse il
dangereux dangereux vraiment même à la
fois pour la politique intérieure qu'à
l'international il a le doigt sur le
bouton comme on dit familièrement et
depuis 1 le procureur robert mueller a
publié en fait a remis son rapport
vendredi dernier le procureur général a
publié une lettre de quatre pages où on
y lit tu y as aucune collusion entre
l'équipe de campagne de crampes et la
russie n'ont pu que qu'iliad entrave à
la justice alors doit-on encore craint
de la manière d'exercer
le pouvoir pour femmes je parlais tout à
l'heure à bob woodward l'un des
journalistes les plus influents de
l'histoire politique américaine il ya
entre autres dévoilé le scandale du
watergate avec son collègue buntin ce
qui a mené à la démission de richard
nixon il était de passage à montréal à
24,60 beau dans votre dernier livre vous
décrivez la peur et le chaos
la maison blanche un président qui pour
bien des gens et paranoïaque un menteur
et bien d'autres choses
pouvez vous nous dire brièvement comment
vous décrire y met ce jour aujourd'hui
réponse ce que j'ai trouvé ma dame en
deux ans de recherche
c'est que la maison blanche de trumpf
traverse une dépression nerveuse
le président de chambre ne sais pas
comment gouverner il prend des risques
en politique étrangère en tout la
relation avec la corée du nord
la relation que la chimie et des enjeux
économiques tels que les tarifs par
exemple il a pris des risques dans sa
relation avec le canada également et ce
nouvel accord de la délinquance ond
l'analyse ses 1800 sage des cliniques
mais au fond celui aucune amélioration
il clame que c'est le meilleur accord
commercial jamais négocié mais deux ou
vous c'est bien des paroles biais de
bruit souvent avec aucun objectif est
discernable
on verra bien c'est ce nouvel à l'ena ça
à prouver mais beaucoup d'experts
partout sur l'échiquier politique de la
gauche comme de la droite
constate que ce nif aucune amélioration
quand il est question d'aider les gens
d'affaires par exemple où les
agriculteurs audois depuis dimanche
dernier on a un président en triomphant
avec cette lettre de quatre pages à du
procureur général ben le président chun
a ses raisons d'être triomphant face aux
conclusions ne devraient pas triomphant
mais soulagé car c'était une enquête
très sérieuse de monsieur moleux et l'a
constaté qu'il n'y avait aucune
collusion entre l'équipe de john et le
gouvernement russes et la question de
l'obstruction de justice des décès
d'arrêter l'inquiète
monsieur moller n'a pas trouvé de preuve
concluante que le président avait commis
un crime mais ils ne l'ont pas disculpé
alors c'est un peu ambigu à cet égard
c'est un grand soulagement pour chacun
en même temps les uns qu'elles ne vont
pas disparaître les enquêteurs du bureau
du procureur fédéral dans l'état de new
york ont tout plein de santi et des
tentacules surtout quand il est question
des finances n'est ce pas - d'or mes
propres recherches ma propre enquête
je me suis entretenu avec des gens qui
n'ont pas encore été rencontré par les
enquêteurs de new york donc je crois que
ça va se prolonger ça va continuer mais
c'est vraiment un point tournant dans le
volet russe question estimez-vous que
les conclusions de série par le
procureur général ben viable créé des
blues
du maquillage écoutez et eu tellement de
gens dans l'entourage de roms qui ont eu
des contacts avec les russes pourtant
réponse est oui mais le simple fait
d'avoir des contacts avec les russes ne
veulent pas nécessairement dire que
c'était une coordination une approprié
où il légal avec les russes et voilà ce
que l'équipe de mollo a conclu qu'il n'y
avait pas de coordination et ça c'est
vraiment important maintenant est ce à
dire qu'il fait un bon travail ou que
c'était inopportun
c'était tout probablement il n'en porte
c'est vrai mais agir de façon
inopportune ce n'est pas un crime aux
états unis donc nous verrons comment ça
va évoluer mais de laisser entendre
comme vous le faites et à juste titre ex
que c'est un grand triomphe
c'est important c'est vrai c'est un
point tournant
je vous la corde et peut-être en fait le
moment le plus important des deux
premières années de la présidence de
monsieur trompe mais ce n'est pas
terminé
vous savez et c'est vers cette
transaction commerciale y appelait de
versement il y à tous ses membres de sa
famille c'est vraiment tentaculaire
alors resté attaché rajouter peut-être
un baudrier madame donc il a bien
d'autres raisons de craindre les
procureurs fédéraux de l'état new york
n'est ce pas pour bien des gens c'est ça
le vrai rapport me muller doux et c'est
ce à quoi ils se réfèrent quand il parle
des inquiète n'est ce pas c'est tout à
fait possible madame de nouveau il va
nous falloir c'est que voyez vous j'ai
passé de nombreuses années à inquiéter
charland sur le scandale du watergate il
ya 45 ans le résultat de toute enquête
comme celle ci se font sur la qualité
des éléments preuve connexion il y avait
des milliers d'heures d'enregistrements
secrets
sur l'esl a démontré le président qui
émettait des directives pour des crimes
des pots de vin à faire sauter des
coffres forts
c'était une litanie de gestes criminels
enregistré on n'avait jamais vu ça
auparavant
et peut-être on ne reverra plus jamais
cela
pour monsieur james ils n'ont pas
d'enregistrement ce n'est pas évident
savez-vous s'ils seront en mesure de
présenter des argumentaires qui vont
tenir devant les tribunaux de combattre
dans ce brouillard dans quatre pendant
des années à venir
question à moins que nous ayons ses
déclarations de revenus n'est ce pas et
toutes ces transactions immobilières et
autres réponse oui c'est vrai j'aurais
souhaité les obtenir en 2016 ou si
quelqu'un dans les médias auraient pu
mettre le grappin dessus
moi j'y travaillais mais peut-être
franchement je n'ai pas été suffisamment
agressif
j'aurais dû les retrouver parce que les
gens qui connaissent le milieu de
l'immobilier à new york
ils me disent que c'est vous aviez
retrouver cela vous auriez la feuille de
route sur la vraie nature de me semble
et si vous parlez aux gens qui ont
transigé avec lui dans la ville de new
york
quand il concluait des transactions avec
lui ils faisaient tout pour structurer
le financement juridique pour que tu
chantes ne puisse pas retirer des fonds
lille est de trésorerie parce qu'il lui
faudrait faire cela et il parlait
toujours de monsieur chambres et des
transactions comme ayant ce risque et
chante et je pense que ce risque
champagne guilmet et bien c'est ce que
nous vivons maintenant aux états unis
l'amérique question donc vous craignez
toujours monsieur oddworld les
agissements du président pour les deux
dernières années de mandat
réponse des découvertes
en écrivant des égards tic pour le
washington post des livres sur neuf
présidence de nexen jusqu'à 30% des
présents qu on lui en fait depuis ces
années c'est que le président a des
pouvoirs extraordinaires et cela en
vertu de notre constitution mais aussi
en pratique je pense que trump a plus de
pouvoir que tout autre président
précédent
il l'a exploité avec ses gazouillis
quotidien en rencontrant les médias et
la réalité c'est que les présidences à
eux seuls peuvent déclencher des guerres
de façon intentionnelle ou même
accidentelle était c'est un des périls
quotidien aux etats unis aujourd'hui
question vous vous rappellerez monsieur
audois de cette lettre d'opinion en
septembre dans le new york times c'était
presque en même temps que la sortie de
votre livre aux états unis c'était une
personne ou plusieurs personnes qui
voulait rassurer les américains qu'il y
avait un adulte dans la pièce qu'ils
étaient là autour de monsieur shop pour
protéger l'amérique et protéger ces
exceptions voir sa démocratie notre
connaissance à ce que cette personne ou
ces personnes toujours là tant de gens
ont quitté même le général kelly n'est
plus de la partie
réponse je ne connais pas l'identité de
la personne ce qui manquait dans cette
lettre c'était d'aider times se fait
probant pour des rencontres précise des
paroles sites est monsieur chante dans
mon livre à moi par exemple il y as tout
cela vous le savez exactement n'est ce
pas on sait qu'elle est à la discussion
quel était l'enjeu qui a dit quoi qui a
pu avoir un moment de colère les mots
prononcés par mois cette chambre et dans
cette lettre d'opinion publiée dans le
new york times s'est jamais cette
personne est venue me voir j'aurais
demandé quels sont les détails
et si j'avais pas reçu les détails je
leur ai dit allez le faire publiée dans
le new york times un joie très bien la
concurrence entre votre journal est la
leur j'aimerais vous entendre là dessus
parce que dans votre livre monsieur
goodwood
vous parlez de témoins en temps réel
avec monsieur shop qui se dispute avec
ses conseillers avec ses fonctionnaires
ses ministres on a vraiment l'impression
d'être là présent ou avec monsieur mollo
d'autres ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'on se demande aujourd'hui s'il a
vraiment quelqu'un dans son entourage en
mesure de protéger les institutions et
les règles de la démocratie puisqu'il
est tellement irrationnelle
réponse il ya bien les gens là qui font
leur travail mais le travail du
président c'est de protéger le pays
ça c'est son rôle le fai ou de constater
la nature profonde de monsieur jack il
aime prendre des risques dans le livre
je décris un nombre d'incidents où les
ministres ou les gens clé la maison
blanche vont lui demander mais pourquoi
pensez-vous
ceci ou cela et le présente comme le
répond eh bien j'ai pris cette décision
je pense là depuis trente ans un si vous
êtes en désaccord avec moi vous êtes
dans l'erreur
question quelles sont vos attentes
maintenant déjà l'issue de très près
l'actualité
avez vous déjà commencé à écrire sur les
deux dernières années de ce premier
mandat de nous cette chance
mais jobs se voit je vois je pense
depuis ce dimanche comme s'il était déjà
réélu en vain
pensez vous que le rapport mieux ou
monsieur bas rhône est actée sur les
lecteurs américains le soutien dont il
jouit réponse sauvé coûte et cela
certainement un impact mais le président
jean klein pas été réélus croyez-moi on
l'a eue ces élections de mi-mandat
l'année dernière et puis c'était le
sondage parfait quand vous y pensez les
gens qui ont réellement voté et on a vu
cette transition de 10% vers le parti
démocrate à la chambre des représentants
et donc maintenant la chambre est
maintenant contrôlée par les démocrates
et amis des égards c'est peut-être un
signe avant coureur de ce qui arrivera
en 20 20 n'est ce pas manifestement
beaucoup de gens sont mal à l'aise sont
malheureux et sont vraiment préoccupé
par la tournure des choses sous le choc
en même temps c'est vrai il a un groupe
de partisans passionnés
donc ça va être un spectacle politique
passionnant dans les deux années à venir
finalement monsieur oddworld pensez vous
que les américains seront davantage
intéressé dans les enjeux tels que la
santé l'obamacare plutôt que les
conclusions du rapport muller par
exemple réponse écoutez c'est bien
possible parce que n'oubliez pas que
chacun d'entre nous on vit sa propre vie
nous le préoccupations de santé sont les
préoccupations clés de chaque individu
et donc cela n'impacte sur le tissu
social
on se demande aussi si l'économie va
être stabilisé est ce que ça va bien
aller où est ce qu'il y aura un
ralentissement économique
je me suis entretenu avec un agent de la
cia et je lui demandais comment ça se
passe dans le monde et la personne m'a
répondu écoutez monsieur oddworld la
mèche de l'instabilité est allumée dans
une vingtaine de pays autour du monde et
les choses pourraient
explosez d'une minute à l'autre ou
peut-être un horizon de cinq ans
peut-être jamais mais ce n'est pas une
situation qui est stable je demande à
quelqu'un d'autre dans le milieu du
renseignement et il m'a dit 20 20 pays
et bien sa sévère au bas mot monsieur
oddworld alors il ya beaucoup de risques
dans le monde et de nouveau c'est parce
que le président est le commandant en
chef des forces armées et le leader des
états unis d'amérique et ce serait
peut-être mieux de concevoir cela comme
étant le risque donald merci monsieur
audois
[Musique]